armoire is at the port of Aden Yemen
every day to watch the fisherman
returned from the sea he used to be one
of them
until he lost his hand in an attack by
government forces as we were preparing
to go to sea we were suddenly attacked
I ran to help an injured colleague but
there was a second attack and I was
flung to the ground I lost my hand and
it's deprived me of an income the 23
years old was the sole breadwinner in
the family after his father was
paralyzed in a motorcycle incident I
used to be a fisherman but after my
accident we depend on Omar now we're
both crippled we went to see ourselves
to check out the rest fishermen take
there is no official agreement with the
Saudi UAE quality' and government forces
fighting Houthis as to how far out
Yemenis can take their boats into the
Red Sea we have entered now the fourth
mile from the coastline of Allah day
that we can see here one of the
fishermen who was using the traditional
fishing he couldn't go further fearing
for his life the seaports authority and
how they do which is run by the Hafiz
says fishermen have been targeted before
me fishermen could not go to areas 20 to
30 miles off the coastline where fish
are available in big quantities for fear
of being attacked by Saudi warships and
Apache helicopters Human Rights Watch
says 46 fishermen have been killed since
the start of the war more than four
years ago but the Port Authority puts
that figure much higher at 267 and
supported one of the victims was a child
14 years old
Human Rights Watch said a child was on a
fishing boat and waved at a helicopter
who showed off the box of fish that they
had caught but he was the first one
killed now we asked them what is your
next move will you raise such in
Justices at the international court of
justice
with Ford in short supply Yemen DC at
least provides a source of meals and
work for her date as a fisherman market
is busy but has itself been attacked
during the war every day a challenge for
Yemenis at sea and on land
hawa pop al Jazeera Al Hoda